merci l'ami qui est avec lui reste avec
toile alors jamie je sais pas si vous le
savez mais aussi on un duo de
scientifiques dans l'émission qui
s'appelle pas fred et jamy mes frais des
gens me et c'est le même système que le
vôtre ya fred qui posent des questions
et la jambe qui répond regardez
[Musique]
je ne sais pas vous mais je me suis
toujours demandé comment on fait pour
devenir le chroniqueur préféré du cndd à
des gens mais tu sais comment on fait
c'est très simple il suffit par exemple
de toujours lui dire ses quatre vérités
c'est à dire c'est le plus beau c'est le
plus grand c'est le plus fort et il a un
énorme talent
ils ont mis je me pose encore une
question comment on fait pour critiquer
serena et ben c'est très simple a aussi
regardé comment constituer une mâchoire
et ben il suffit pour cela de fermer sa
gueule oh non j'ai passé l'argent c'est
vraiment embêtant
je me demande vraiment comment on fait
vous demander une augmentation s écrit
dan dah les gens mais tu sais toi c'est
très simple là aussi il suffit d'y
mettre un tout petit peu les formes
tu prends une feuille un silo et tu
écris avec ta plus belle écriture
cyril je te demande solennellement une
petite augmentation est tué de la lettre
après tu prends la feuille tulle
appuyons 4 et après tu te la colle
délicatement dans les fesses voilà à
l'échec parcelles direction de pôle
emploi
[Applaudissements]
une seule bombe rabobank s'est dit
également